hi everyone I'm here at the University
of Sydney today I've got one familiar
face Peter over here that's gone ever
since Gabe and Leah everyone here is
interested in physics physics education
and we've got some experiments set up
for you so the first is the Van de
Graaff generator so this is I guess all
about static charge and electricity so
you can see it a bit of a discharge of
electricity between these two poles
maybe Peter or someone else has set this
up tell me what your explanation of it
is well so the basic idea is that
remember they that experiment that you
did
hopefully in primary school maybe high
school where you take a plastic rod or a
ruler and you rub it with a piece of
cloth a piece of felt and then you put
it next to some water or like a tissue
or some paper or whatever and that
stream of water is slightly attracted to
us that ruler that is basically it's
separating the charges right to create
you know the pull all right so that's
kind of what's happening here there's a
one part of this contraption is becoming
really strongly charged and the other
one isn't as strongly charged and then
it sparks across the air yeah there's a
gap as a rule of thumb every centimeter
that a spark arcs across air is between
15,000 to 30,000 volts depending on kind
of the humidity and all those kind of
things so it's goddess
[Music]
that's a lot of bolts someone do the
math quick three hundred thousand volts
on a good day this can do about 30
centimeters park today is not good so
[Music]
you're saying there's three hundred
thousand volts and there's a thing here
and there's a lot of us around and
there's this foam thing on the floor
yeah I'm worried
so bones that eat you like you for the
probably next thing we're going to end
up doing but you can safely stand cut
you loose and build up a lot of chalk
and we should see hopefully some
interesting things happening it would
hurt yeah yeah instead of discharging
into the grounding ball there which is
nicely classic Brown so it doesn't
matter you would be ideal shall we try
okay
it was a nice tip thrown around facts I
know you when you hold one of these your
hair stops to stand on it because I get
each strand of your hair has the same
charge and like they decide to repel
each other I have quite okay I guess I
could try take mine out and see if it
does anything else on the generator my
suspicion is that bike might be too
heavy like each other that your strand I
think maybe the witness on the line and
then you guys can try off the bay but
I've never tried all of these since I've
had fun
[Music]
[Music]
do your hair shoot yeah even you go oh
my god that's amazing that's so cool
cameraman how's it are any of the longer
strands like yeah like those ones a star
could push out get all the frame these
shouldn't hurt you nice I'm not good all
right can you see that yeah yep you can
see it a little bit
is that a charge to work first back so
it could be completely have a look at
the back that hair strand I did that
once play I'm off that's so amazing
holy crap so you know this isn't the
biggest Van de Graaff generator I did
the same no but they're like I'm much
bigger ones that exist where the charge
build-up would be a lot more yeah yeah
so I mean I don't think I can get all my
hair spaniel didn't get this one but
maybe in Brussels it's amazing
alright and you can see it clearly
affecting the pocket yeah which is
slightly scary is how conductive is hair
if I touch one of your strands of hair
we will hear this discharge will there
be and I think so but if you do touch
the ones back okay it's fully towards me
oh that's pulling away towards Toby do
feel look I can feel that yep we have a
spa so just hand straight up around your
hair to drop straight down that's all
the cards right we're two men showed up
yeah yeah touch touch the table he touch
me very good nice all right
every time this part let's go
all right there's always gonna be so
dominant Inc yeah Toby this might be
your experience as well every time I do
this there's this like I know the
physics and I know that it's safe and I
trust the equipment and I trust Liam and
I years and years of education I have
but it still feels weird scary and I
can't see I know I know
ya know I but I feel I feel so you can
actually take your hand off whoa wait
whoa yeah whoa why is it making that
noise
well the discharge
oh you'll have a different potential
between there and there yeah so you can
actually don't do it yet but you can
take your hands off a little bit and
then put it back on for like a few
seconds look at that
I would kill a hand drum well you're
you're doing that yeah because the
charge is going to yeah we'll see I'm
now I'm acting like the lightning rod
yeah yeah great so sorry what I'm gonna
do now is I'm gonna let go of my house
and I'm gonna put it back on because
your child should be the same right so
you the reason you're not getting shot
is goes to the same guy gets it when you
take your hands off
you should stay relatively the same guy
could you inflate from the ground and
that's not gonna build up too much rock
take it off okay put it back on and you
shouldn't get to that's the whole thing
yeah sure sure is now the bits like you
know so so a year ago that was the show
with Todd Sampson put life on the line
and like I thought the premise
originally was kinda lame and then like
genuinely when he did a bungee jump with
a with a phone book like connecting the
two elastic wires I was like man this
dude gets it like this is actually
insane it's like one thing to know you
know the theory and the the tests of it
and then the other thing is to actually
fund you jump with the phone book yeah
yeah all right so three two one one
three does not come back it will jump
into time yeah good so I get up all
discharge and then we fist bump again I
can't do it
all right all right
your turn yes you hit the table you'll
stop me yep good physics am i right
science guy good science like we know
we've done too much when that woke up
the back just go down yeah the closer I
come out it's cool it's been real way
down here beside explore experiment sees
that was strangely melted piece of
missile and he told me that this is a
lightning rod yeah it's a lightning rod
that actually was at the University of
Sydney and it was hit by lightning and
then all the current around it basically
created a strong magnetic magnetic field
that basically pulled itself together
station yeah so it deformed from like a
solid like the pike that it is with a
hollow opening as you can see and like
the pipe shot itself and the closing
self oh yeah pinched itself together so
it's actually cold
the pinch effect and there's a
demonstration of this here and we're not
doing it because there's one of the
transformers is broken and we don't want
to blow
card and here that basically does that
and also happen in this debate yeah all
right let's give it some more
experiments yeah